In the circle below,
central angle GOH
has a measure of 3/2 radians.
What is the length of arc GH?
So let's define
some variables that
will help us manipulate
them a little bit easier.
So where is central angle GOH?
It's this angle right over here.
Let's call that theta.
So let's say that theta is equal
to the measure of angle GOH.
Now they're asking us,
what's the length of arc GH?
Well, arc GH is this
right over here.
And let's call that s.
So let's let s be equal
to the length of arc GH.
And they also give
us the radius is
6 centimeters for this circle.
But let's just call
that r for now.
So the radius is equal
to 6 centimeters.
So the first thing
that we should
think about when we're dealing
with arc lengths and radians
is how do angles measured in
radians relate to arc length?
In particular, how does an
angle measured in radians
relate to the length of the
arc that subtends that angle?
And in this case, the length
of this arc right over here,
arc GH, subtends angle theta,
subtends central angle GOH.
So what's the relationship?
Well, the definition
of radian measure
says that an angle
measured in radians
is the ratio between
the length of arc
that subtends that angle, so s,
and the radius of the circle.
If this was a unit circle,
then it would just literally
be equal to that arc length.
If it's not a unit circle--
or, I guess, in all cases,
unit circle or
not-- it's the ratio
between the length
of the arc that
subtends the angle
and the radius.
Now given this definition,
really, of what a radian is,
let's see what we know
and what we don't know.
And we can manipulate
this however we see fit.
You could see this written as if
you multiply both sides of this
by r, you get r
theta is equal to s.
Or another way of
writing it is you
could get s is equal to r theta.
And we could have solved this
equation or this equation.
But for this problem,
this one's actually
going to be a little
bit useful because this
is the unknown,
the length of GH.
We want to know what this is.
This is the unknown
that they're asking for.
And this explicitly
solves for the unknown.
So this has essentially
solved it for us.
So what else do we know?
Well, we know the radius.
We know the radius
is 6 centimeters.
We multiply that times
the angle in radians,
which is 3/2 radians.
And we are left with, so s
is equal to 6 centimeters
times 3/2.
And so we are left with, this
is going to be equal to 6 times
3 is 18 divided by 2 is 9.
It's going to be equal
to 9 centimeters.
And we are done.